Oh
[Music]
so you know I think a lot about the
transformative power of cinema the
interpersonal impact of a great film a
great film can awaken us to our inner
genius a great film get him print itself
in our consciousness and transform us
from within
you know the French in a wave filmmaker
Godard said that cinema was truth 24
times per second Jean Youngblood
expanded on business book expand the
cinema
he says cinema reflects mankind's
historical urged to Anna fest his
consciousness new theory already outside
of his mind in front of his eyes cinema
is a mirror we hold up to ourselves that
reveals us to ourselves it's a dream
sharing technology that allows us to
visit the space of truth of archetype of
myth of legend it's the magical
borderland it's the story world in which
we lose ourselves and we find ourselves
the book cartographic cinema goes even
farther it says that cinema is
cartography for the mind cinema is a map
for consciousness offering us
orientation in this imaginal realm of
dream and of course with such power
comes great responsibility then
as a tool as a technique for such
cathartic illumination means that
filmmakers have a responsibility to
craft work that thrusts the human spirit
into the numinous we need to expand the
consciousness of society as filmmakers
as craftsmen of the lens this is our
responsibility that's right
[Music]
you